-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The Biden administration
announced yesterday
that it will reopen
U.S. land borders next month
with Canada and Mexico,
but only to travelers
who are fully vaccinated
against the coronavirus,
because let's face it --
if you're not vaccinated,
you're not safe here.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
is set this week to host
a virtual
counter-ransomware summit
to discuss ways to combat
global cybercriminal networks.
I'm sorry -- this guy
wants to talk cybercrime?
What's his advice gonna be?
"I write my password
on the back of a Post-it."
[ Laughter ]
"They never look at the back!"
Former President Trump
is reportedly close to a deal
to sell his company's
Washington, D.C., hotel
to Spirit Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] According --
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a new report
from the Congressional
Budget Office,
federal tax revenues went up
by 18% in the last fiscal year,
which is the largest
one-year jump in 44 years.
Everyone got so bored
during quarantine,
they actually did their taxes.
"I dunno, it's this
or play Scrabble again."
The FDA yesterday authorized
an electronic cigarette
for the first time,
because one way or another,
they will vaccinate Florida.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Social Security --
The Social Security
Administration announced today
that beneficiaries will see
a 5.9% increase
in their benefit checks
next year.
Said Grandma, "Get in, bitch!"
[ Laughter ]
Actor Mark Harmon on Monday
exited the show "NCIS"
after 18 seasons.
Man, and Grandma was having
such a good day
with that Social Security news.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
"Get in, bitch!"
"No, Grandma,
you've got to get out.
I have some Mark --
I have some Mark Harmon news."
The fast food chain Wendy's
has announced a new partnership
with Google to implement
artificial intelligence
to improve the quality
of their restaurants.
And if you want the chili,
just click on "Feeling Lucky."
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterday
that "Squid Game"
is officially its biggest-ever
series launch.
But remember, their
second-biggest launch
was the 1981 BBC show
"Old Scottish Detective."
[ Laughter ]
That was Baze and I --
that was our favorite joke
of the day.
[ Laughter ]
And let me tell you,
if none of you were here,
it would've gone just as well
as all the other jokes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That's right, "Squid Game" is
officially the biggest ever
Netflix series launch.
Even more disturbing --
Sallie Mae wants to option
the idea for student loans.
[ Laughter ]
And final--
Move over,
"Old Scottish Detective"!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
Those were our two
"Squid Game" jokes.
[ Laughter ]
The biggest show --
The biggest show,
and we're like, "Here's the way
we're gonna go at it."
"Old Scottish Detective,"
student loans.
[ Laughs ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
11% of Americans said that
they always use their phone
while going to the bathroom.
The rest use toilet paper.
[ Laughter ]
Scollins!
That was a monologue, everybody.